good morning everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today
his SCP 2750 object class Euclid special
containment procedures currently the
foundation has three SCP 2750 instances
in containment SCP 2750 instances are
not permitted to change their
appearances for any reason any changes
in appearance are to be noted an SCP
2750 instances are to be punished
accordingly
by revoking certain privileges capture
of uncontained SCP 2750 instances is
difficult due to the aversion that SCP
2750 instances shell towards humans and
the rarity of SCP 2750 instances
themselves containment teams are to
conduct a monthly sweep of the areas
where SCP 2750 instances have been known
to inhabit description SCP 2750 is the
collective designation referring to a
group of anomalous humanoids that are
known to inhabit the southwest united
states specifically the regions of
northeast arizona in southern Utah
notably the area of the Navajo Nation
reservation SCP 2750 specimens heavily
resemble non-anomalous humans of navajo
descent following this trend SCP 2750
instances invariably wear clothing and
masks associated with navajo culture of
the 1800s beyond their stated anomalous
properties SCP 2750 instances resemble
normal humans from a biological
standpoint as CP 2750 instances
demonstrate the ability to change their
appearances in body shapes to various
animals found in the southwestern United
States
particularly those that are prominent
did Navajo culture such as coyotes foxes
wolves Eagles and crows
this effect is voluntarily triggered and
all captured as CP 2750 instances have
shown the ability to change into at
least five different animals though
field reports have suggested that
certain instances possess the ability to
change into nine or more different
animals all at CP twenty seven fifty
instances possessed eyes that resemble
their favorite animal to mimic despite
possessing animal-like eyes most SCP
twenty seven fifty instances demonstrate
normal human vision it is currently
estimated that roughly a hundred SCP
2750 instances exist outside of
containment SCP 27 50 instances have
been noted to travel in migratory groups
pursuing a hunter-gatherer lifestyle
interviews with captured specimens
suggest a tribal structure akin to that
practice by the navajo people in the
pre-columbian period a CP 2750 specimens
have shown extreme aversion to human
contact SCP 2750 migration patterns
specifically avoid any sign of human
settlement and all discovered instances
seem to have instinctual fear of humans
despite their close proximity to the
Navajo Nation reservation no SCP 2750
instance has ever been found within the
territory of the reservation itself no
SCP 2750 instance has been encountered
in the field since 1983 though signs of
habitation from SCP 2750 have been found
such as the remains of campfires tracks
and temporary encampments SCP 2750
instances demonstrate expertise in many
bushcraft skills which is believed to
have given them their ability to evade
foundation capture to date all known
captured SCP 2750 specimens were
impaired in some way such as by disease
injury or exile from SCP 2750 society
accounts of SCP 2750 have existed since
the 17th century when European settlers
first made contact with the Navajo
people said people gave the first
description of SCP 2752 a Catholic
missionary by the name of Ferdinand
Cortez which is currently the oldest
record of SCP 2750 s existence the
noteworthy portion of his letter is
transcribed here translated from old
Spanish following the meeting the
natives described at length some manner
of beasts that plagues them much
viciously they call it a ye not la XI
from what I gathered this creature
endeavors to invade the privacy of their
homes to devastate the people within the
Beast is of a mindless temperament
aggressive and deadly in addition these
beasts may adopt the skin of all
varieties of animals to bewitched the
minds of men as well as calling in a
voice so pure and innocent a man would
not dare to question it some prefer the
skin of a human while others prefer the
ways of the common animals I am most
worried however by their claims as to
the unholy abilities of these beasts one
of their shaman's swore up and down that
they could know whatever a man was
pondering with the lightest force of
will should one of them glare at any
poor soul the unfortunate man shall lose
control of his limbs and mind
had I not witnessed one of these
monsters with my very own eyes I should
not have believed such an outlandish
story I am of the opinion that these
knob washi present nothing less than a
highly dangerous threat to the peace
there bellicosity about the natives
along with a much feared tracking and
hunting ability leads me to fear some
expansion or violence to the people of
our country I write you this letter and
send it through the fastest channels so
that you may send a response here to
quell any sort of unrest from these
creatures
SCP 2750 s existence to the public has
been concealed under the
patterson-gimlin protocol which has
successfully decreased knowledge of a CP
2750 to the point of cultural fiction
cultural knowledge of SCP 2750 among the
Navajo people persists though this is
mostly for historical purposes and not
due to the active belief in its
existence by the majority of the
population active enforcement of the
patterson-gimlin protocol for Navajo
groups additional SCP 2750 documentation
during transference of SCP objects from
SCP to foundation control numerous
documents were discovered that pertained
to SCP 2750 upon review by the newly
established foundation's ethics
committee these documents were sealed
from general viewership they have been
reproduced here in their entirety
document 2751 this document is continued
from the earlier letter presented in the
description furthermore the shaman's
begged us of our support in eradicating
these creatures from the earth being as
we are in need of allies in the region I
saw no reason not to accept the medicine
man's offer and be rid of a dangerous
beast at the same time the nod la she
eyes seemed to live in some savage
tribal cult much like the natives
themselves I am of the opinion that this
requires more investigation so we ought
not be caught in an unpleasant situation
where we know nothing of our fault
document 27:52 the following is a
telegram dated September 2nd 1877
approximately three months after the
above letter is believed to have been
sent field report initial assault
successful stop casualties minimal stop
complete surprise
stop native allies please stop
cavalry fortifying . document 27:53 the
following is a telegram dated to
September 5th 1877 field report
devastating counter-attack stop animals
in camp attacked stop casualties hi 89
kill 289 wounded all forces retreat him
stop immediate reinforcements requested
. document 2754 the following is a
series of telegrams found archived
together they are dated December 7th
1857 March 7th 1857 and June 7th 1877
respectively field report quarterly
casualties 43 killed 90 wounded stop
native casualties 87 killed 192 wounded
stop enemy casualty estimates 125 killed
502 wounded stop fortifications in place
stop constant raids stop cannot progress
into enemy territory stop request
artillery
full stop field report quarterly US
casualties 26 killed 75 wounded stop
native casualties 63 killed 143 wounded
stop enemy casualty estimates 89 killed
297 wounded stop successful use of
artillery stop advance good stop disease
spread an enemy stop expect quick
victory full stop
field report quarterly US casualties 182
killed 782 wounded stop native
casualties 409 killed 873 wounded stop
enemy casualty estimates 831 kill 1076
wounded stop enemy offensive bloody stop
request more troops stop no trust
animals full stop document 2755 the
following is a letter dated to November
25th 1877 it is believed to have been
addressed to territorial governor John
Orville director Orville the null Vashi
war is concluded to our success were at
I to choose though success is a poor
word heavy na glossy resistance is all
but gone as all leaders are dead or
captured yet for this cost
we paid nearly 400 lives and our allies
more than a thousand we counted and
burned over 2,000 enemy corpses I fear
that sporadic war will continue for
years to come until the enemy is totally
eradicated but seeing the strengths of
this foe it may be many many years until
it is truly over I hope it was all worth
it John Colonel William Tyson 7th
Cavalry Regiment
[Music]
document 27:56 the following is an
interview with the first captured SCP
2750 instance the instance was captured
following a battle between American
militia and an SCP 2750 raiding party
the instance spoke exclusively in the
Navajo language the interview has been
translated from Navajo to English for
ease of access playing log now
damn you damn you are and mathilde so
you drown your children the fire of hash
Cassini will purge your souls from this
world please tell me so you dare speak
to me in such a manner you who speak the
language of the Danai has betrayed our
people so who are you to speak to me you
are nothing to us and your punishment
will be swift once you die I do not
understand what you're saying do not
mock me slave tongue I'm not mocking you
clean lies first you've shown us for our
arts and gifts that you so jealously
coveted then you attacked us provoking
ceaseless warfare that has devastated us
both then you twisted us into
unimaginable monsters in order to
destroy us and now you have the gall to
insult me so I do not understand what
you are saying can you elaborate I've
heard what you have said of us you
called us mine breeders and violent
beasts as if we were no better than the
worms that crawl through the earth has
some sort of creature that was devoted
to evil our people are dying thanks to
your lies and then B of our gift blood
is under our hands brother and our
people patterson-gimlin protocol the
patterson-gimlin protocol is currently
in effect for SCP 2750 active awareness
of SCP 2750 is to be encouraged as a
cultural phenomenon due to the inability
to properly contain awareness of the
anomaly at this present stage all
personnel should consult the procedural
handbook for general containment for
more information
directors note 2750 today at the
foundation we are able to pride
ourselves on our ability to contain
anomalies with a minimum of visibility
collateral damage and suffering this
however was not the case for one of our
forebears in the American theater of
anomaly containment the Americans secure
containment initiative from time to time
we rediscover artifacts and anomalies
that were badly butchered thanks to 19th
century containment quackery and
political motivations it is our duty to
clean up these messes of our ancestors
SCP 2715 may be the most blatant example
of this the documents currently on
display for level 3 researchers are only
a fraction of what we have on SCP 2750
while they do accurately portray some
components of the American secure
containment than issued its role in the
Indian Wars they do not mention the
unexpected side effects you see Navajo
mythology is never stated that SCP 2750
ever had a limit on the number of
transformations possible and we've never
found a reason why SCP 2750 appearances
have dwindled at a faster rate than
expected even following the purges we
recently found a new SCP 2750 instance
in 2008 yes the file is wrong but that's
because the new instance we found was
very very different this one couldn't
transform properly so it was stuck in a
state between a coyote and a human what
we gathered from it was that this is
becoming the new norm among SCP 2750
populations
apparently the factor that allows us EP
2750 is to some degree genetic
the dwindling genetic pool has led to
inbreeding that causes improper
transformations in addition the
increasing difficulty of finding game to
hunt in the American Southwest has
caused a dramatic decrease in SCP 2750
populations the previous site director
and the security committee that he
assembled deemed that further knowledge
of this development would be dangerous
to site morale and chose not to reveal
this information publicly the last thing
we need
he said his more researchers taking pity
on anomalies indeed we are not kind to
anomalies that we contain and we do not
seek to humanize them however we do not
destroy our anomalies we treat them in a
logical manner in this particular case
the wholesale destruction of an entire
anomalous population thanks to political
motives and shoddy evidence is
inexcusable never forget the
consequences of your decisions anything
you choose to do here should not be
taken lightly
Jeremiah Whitfield site director
well now I'm just depressed thank you
all for listening if indeed you still
are and you're all dismissed go away
I would like to give a special thank you
to slump god Justin day John Porter
fluffy Pierce M Hamlin white crew beware
600 my archive curator neck tie verbal
Kody tench cheese whip dips McGee and
oblong dish boy if you would like a
special thank you at the end of each of
my videos on some other cool stuff as
well visit patreon.com forward slash the
Volgin thank you
[Music]
you